uh thank you thank you all for being
here and welcome to you shall not
password my name is eli holdeness and
i'm going to be talking to you about
authenticating your users over the web
if this is something that you've ever
looked into before you'll probably be
familiar with some of the following
things a username and password-based
login system
you can do all kinds of single sign-on
login with existing accounts that you
already have elsewhere you might have
two-factor authentication with something
like your biometrics fingerprints or
getting one-time passwords sent to a
device like a phone and you might even
use something like an authenticator app
like duo um this can all get a little
bit bewildering
the reason i care is because i work at
anvil which is a framework for building
full stack webs with nothing but python
and if we want to provide our users that
is people developing apps with anvil
with a seamless user experience where
they can just
check a box and add any of these options
to their apps we are going to have to
understand this bewildering landscape so
what i'm going to be talking to you
about today is the following what
authentication actually is
and why we should care about it
common ways to authenticate your users
and their pros and cons
and finally what makes an authentication
system good and note that i did not
necessarily use the word secure there
so
what is authentication
what is this thing that everybody talks
about why should we care about it well
let's say that i've built something a
web app for example
and
ideally i have at least one user
that user might have things like they've
got this user has stuff this user has
things like sensitive data payment
information maybe
and they might also have access to
restricted actions like posting under a
given online identity
as the person who is built and is
maintaining this web app i want to be
able to control their access to those
restricted actions
and you know store sensitive data about
them
it's all well and good but ideally
i don't just have one user i have lots
of users
and i want to make sure that only this
user has access to their stuff
or in other words in a format you may be
more familiar with as a web service
provider
i want to verify that a given user
corresponds to a given identity so they
can make sure that they have the
appropriate access to data and actions
based on that identity
so
that is authentication
how do we do it
well it turns out that identity is
really hard to define
even in person laying down exactly what
makes one person different than another
is really quite tricky
and this only gets harder when you're
doing it over the web so rather than
doing it directly which it turns out to
be a deep philosophical problem we just
use abstractions we use things like
knowledge of a password or having a
fingerprint that matches up with what
your scanner thinks it should be and so
on um however there is an issue with
this which is that these are only ever
approximate they are proxies
so
let's take a look at an example that we
all know and love classic username and
password and go through a little bit of
you know look at it through this
framework
so the setup is you have a server that
serves your web service you have a
client that is the front end that the
user interacts with in order to interact
with your web service and finally you
have the user and the user would like to
authenticate and get access to their
stuff
and they say right here are my details
i'll put in my username and my password
client passes those onto the server the
server is able to verify that this
information is correct
um comes back to the client and says
yeah yeah this person is who they say
they are let them get at their stuff
um and under this framework we are
assuming that knowledge of this password
knowledge of this username which you
know typically these days is often an
email address as well is acknowledge of
this secret information is equivalent to
identity if i know the password then i
am that person right
however this isn't necessarily always
true who knows that password
well of the three entities we just
looked at
obviously the user has to know it that's
kind of the whole point
um the client you can just pass it
straight through the client never needs
to actually store the password so that's
all good
um but the server is a bit of an
interesting case because the servers
function in this scenario in this web
flow
is it has to be able to verify the
password it has to be able to know
somehow that that user put in the thing
that the secret that defines their
identity
but it also has a responsibility not to
let that secret get out
because the secret is equivalent to
identity under this framework
you've really really got to make sure
you can't leak it
so
if we were very naive we might do
something like this i've got my server
and i'm just storing records of people's
usernames and their password obviously
then i get past the password by the
client and i can just go yeah it matches
great cool let them in
but if your database has ever leaked if
anybody ever gets access to all of these
records suddenly all of your users have
their identities completely compromised
so what we do instead is we do
we use salted hashes and this hash in
bloom is a one-way function that
basically takes an input string and
turns it into an incomprehensible
mishmash of characters and letters and
all of these different things
and at the end we've added a little bit
of random data
and the purpose of this is that this bit
of random data is different for every
password that you would feed into this
hash function and it makes brute forcing
um like you if you know the hash
function the salt prevents an attacker
from just brute forcing lots of
passwords using the hash function it all
gets a little bit involved but basically
what it means is that the server doesn't
have to store the password it can store
this inscrutable string of characters so
instead what you end up with is you
store my username and the salted hash of
my password
um and the way that we do it the way it
is commonly done is that you have like a
little dollar sign and then after that
is the big longing scriptural string of
numbers and before it is the salt and so
when the server gets the password um
sent to it by the client it can go well
i know i need to add that little that
7af that little bit of extra data to the
end of this feed it into my hash
function compare it to what's after the
dollar sign
and then i know that these things match
and the server never has to store the
password
this is this is much much better than
storing it in plain text don't ever
store passwords in plain text
but
for most passwords if somebody gets hold
of your salted hash it's still really
it's still game over right because if i
have that salted hash and i know what
therefore i know what salt to pass in
with the password and there are only
like a few hash functions that ever get
used i could just brute force like with
a dictionary attack lots of common
passwords right a password like eli's
password would get cracked very very
soon if somebody specifically wanted to
target me and had my salted hash
so
what you end up with is most passwords
are kind of insecure
unless they look something like this to
start with right that's hard to remember
um i'm thinking about you know who else
has to know what's going on what what
the password is
let's go back and think about our user
unfortunately users are people
and this means things like they can
forget their password if you are having
to remember passwords that are big long
inscrutable strings of characters
um that's hard to remember
and moreover if your user forgets their
password this thing that defines their
identity as far as your system is
concerned you need some way to let them
reset that password without compromising
your security
users can also be tempted uh can be
tricked into giving away their password
so
this is a common attack called like
known as a phishing attack whereby one
website um buys up a domain that's very
very close in spelling to another
pretends to be that website and then the
user goes and puts their password for
the legitimate website into the false
one
and
this means that yeah suddenly their
password for that legitimate service has
now been compromised
um
users can be tempted to reuse passwords
particularly if they've gone to the
effort of memorizing some inscrutable
string of numbers and letters
you're going to want to use that
everywhere but if you've been tricked
into giving away your password through a
phishing attack whoever's now got hold
of it can go and try that password with
every online service they think you
might have and if you're reusing that
password all of those accounts are now
compromised
so
this is our you know our classic
username and password model and we can
see that it's it's not quite good enough
right
so how can we do better
one thing we even industry has have
landed on is the idea of multi-factor
authentication
um and this is like you know you you
sign in with a username and password to
your bank and you get a text to your
phone saying this is your one-time
password you need to enter that as well
uh requiring more than one thing in
order to authenticate we have uh my
single lord of the rings meme for this
talk
but what about the second authentication
factor
if we think about identity as uh
authentication as an abstraction over
identity it's essentially the same as
saying well if one abstraction fails um
you know somebody else did get hold of
my password let's require another kind
of success
as an extra layer of security
um
and there are these these factors these
authentication factors that like the
proxies that we use for identity
generally fall into three camps you may
have heard this before if you've sort of
looked into this in detail
you've got things that you know like a
username and password um and these the
the risk here is that you might not be
the only one who knows them right you
can you can forget your password you can
be tricked into giving it away and you
can be tempted to reuse it meaning that
it's less secure
you've got things that you have like
physical access to a phone that can
receive one-time passwords
obviously you could lose these
physically you could have these
physically stolen
and then you lastly you have things you
are biometrics so like fingerprints or
if you're getting really fancy retinol
scans
and the downside with this is that you
can't actually tell nationwide that this
is my fingerprint what you're actually
doing is you're using a piece of
hardware a scanner
to verify that for you so you inherently
have to trust that hardware
also
if that's compromised i can't just get a
new thumb
it's a lot harder to reset biometrics
so if you're doing multi-factor
authentication you have a few options
you might ask for two things that you
know
but an issue with this is that if
somebody's got hold of my password um if
somebody's got hold of one thing i know
right they tricked me into giving it
away or they've cracked it because
they've got access to the database
they could probably use the same method
to get hold of the second thing
so it's often what you'll see with
two-threat authentication is you require
two different types of factors so
something you know and something you
have
and this is this is better because you
probably can't use the same method if
you just because you've managed to crack
my password from having database access
doesn't mean you can steal my phone
so
that's due factual authentication water
break i've already drink some water
there are lots of options for what you
might choose as a second authentication
factor and we are going to go through
them now
uh first up my personal favorite are
hardware authentication tokens
and these look like this they can be
something like a ubi key a usb or a
small roaming device is what they're
called but they can also be built into
larger devices like a phone or a laptop
and they work pretty much the same
and
the way that they work is they use
public key cryptography so very brief
primer on public key cryptography for
anyone who's not already familiar
how this works is that there is a pair
of keys that defines your identity you
have a private key you don't tell
anybody very very secret you have a
public key that you share with everybody
and what you can do is when you send a
message to somebody you can sign it
using that private key and anybody who
has the public key will be able to
verify that it was signed with that
private key without you having to give
away that private key
and this means that anybody receiving a
message can have a very high level of
trust that it was really actually sent
by you and what a hardware
authentication token does is it just
embodies that hard work that that
private key it's baked into it at the
hardware level
so the way that you use them to log into
a service looks like this i've got my
user their client and the server just as
we did before and the user says i would
like to log in please and the client
goes back and says well we ask our users
to have hardware authentication tokens
server please issue an authentication
challenge and this is a message that the
server wants to see signed by that
private key and return to it so it does
that it sends an authentication
challenge to the client
the client says i've got an
authentication challenge please present
your hardware token
the user does and this can be plugging
it into the computer it can connect via
bluetooth nfc if you're on a phone it
might be you unlock it with your
fingerprint
and then that authentication challenge
is passed by the client directly to the
hardware token which then does all the
cryptographic processing it signs it
with the private key that's baked into
it
and then that signed response is sent
back to the client which then sends it
onto the server the server is able to
verify it using its knowledge of your
public key
and then go back to the client and say
this person is who they are let them get
at their stuff
and there are some really interesting
things about this this flow um one of
which is that this device knows about
the web service that authentication
challenge from the server was passed
directly onto the device itself
and one of the things this does is gives
you very strong protection against the
phishing attacks that i mentioned
earlier your hardware token is much much
better at spotting fake websites than
you are
another thing is that the private key
never leaves this device all the
processing is done on the device itself
that authentication challenge is signed
within that hardware not your computer
um and actually if it's a if it's a key
that's built into a larger device
there's actually a layer of separation
there like in hardware that ensures that
this is true even for ones that are
built into laptops and phones
and this means that even if your
computer is riddled with malware that
private key cannot be extracted which is
pretty cool
and even if your computer is riddled
with malware one thing it might do is it
might send lots of spurious
authentication challenges to a connected
device and try and like brute force the
private key that way
and for that reason the device will
often require user presence so if you've
ever used a ub key you'll know that um
often you have to press a button in
order to make it do the cryptographic
processing um and for devices uh keys
that are built into devices you will
often have to do some kind of gesture
like using your fingerprint
in order to make the authentication key
do the thing
and this means that even if you i
connect my ub key to my laptop my
laptop's full of viruses and they start
spamming my ubc trying to figure out its
private key i would have to press the
button every single time in order to do
that and i'm not going to do that
so um hardware tokens they're great
right everybody should have one everyone
should have one love it cherish it don't
lose it
but there are some downsides and one
downside is that they are expensive
if you are going to build a web app and
you want everybody to have to use one of
these you're going to have to be okay
with the fact that some people don't
have them don't want to buy them
don't have access to them
and that is going to limit your usership
the other issue is that you could lose
them right i i've lost keyrings before
i know i could lose a hardware
authentication token um
and if a user does this thing that
defines their identity according to your
framework you need a way to let them
reset that and register a new hardware
token without compromising your security
right
you might notice a theme as we go on
so hardware authentication tokens
one other option that you have for
two-factor authentication is one-time
passwords
so for this this is another thing that
you have
um this is for you when you when you try
and sign into a bank and it says sends
like typically their six-digit codes um
and you have to then input that in order
to log in
and these are pretty good they're a way
of using hardware um without having with
that isn't necessarily a hardware
authentication token especially if
you're using texts uh lots of people
have phones that can receive texts and
you also have the option of using
authenticator apps that are sort of
built into a smartphone or installed on
your smartphone i should say
and the way that you log in with this
looks like this
you've got your user your web app your
server and your device the user says
hello i would like to log in
and the client goes to the server and
says hello please generate a code for
this user and send it to the device that
we have on file for them
that happens and the code is sent to
your device the user then reads it
and inputs it
and
the client goes yes i can verify this
and lets them in to their stuff
and this is this is actually
it works this is a very very widely used
system
one drawback is that if you're using
text messages right
phone numbers access to a phone number
that can um can read texts
is not actually that secure if i go to
your phone service provider i walk into
vodafone and say hey this is my number
but i lost my stem can you issue me a
new one
and if they're secure that now you're
relying on the shop's security to like
and the system security to not let some
just a random person do that because if
they do they could read your text they
can have access to any one-time password
sent to that device
another issue is that
you can lose your phone
and you need to allow people to reset
this device in order to maintain access
to your service
another option is magic link login hands
up here who uses slack
yeah slack does this it's really cool
and what you do is you input your email
and you get a link and it takes you to
an authenticated session in that service
and
looking familiar it's very similar to
the one-time password flow you put in
your email the client says hey server
will you generate a session token for
this person to log into their account
the server does that sends it to the
email the user then clicks on that link
in the email and it takes them back to
the web app but now they are
authenticated and they can get at their
stuff
and one of the reasons this is pretty
good is because if you're on the web
using web services you probably have an
email account even if you don't have a
phone that can receive text messages so
um
one of the one of the talks i forget
which one it was yesterday um the
speaker mentioned a friend who has
text-based
sort of two-factor authentication but
doesn't have signal in their house and
have to run to the end of the road to
get code
um if you're trying to access the web
you probably have access to your email
so this is one way of mitigating that
problem
um
and it can all happen on the same device
right i can access my emails from my
phone click on that link and be taken
into the slack app so it works on like
you only need one device to actually do
this
on the other hand
people can lose access to their emails
we actually see this a lot at anvil with
student accounts people who signed up
under you know a dot edu account or
something that they lose access to once
they graduate and they don't really have
so many different accounts registered
that they don't realize until they've
actually lost access to that account and
then how do you verify their identity
you need some way to let them reset it
without compromising your security i'm
going to sound like a broken record on
this and you will see why
um
one of the reasons that um
oh sorry
anyway we've now looked at a bunch of
different options for two-factor
authentication
and now i want you to think about how
many online accounts you have right like
facebook google twitter tumblr for me
because i am that person you know
pinterest etsy whatever
um
and think about setting up two-factor
authentication but all of them right
that's a lot that's a lot of things to
manage
alternately let's say you have a
software company or you are
like the sysadmin think about how many
online accounts an average employee
needs
github
slack maybe trello or jira
you know and
the you will need to not only set up and
administrate all of these but put
multi-factor authentication on all of
these
it's a lot so two-factor authentication
is great it greatly increases the
security of all your online identities
but that's a lot of overhead
what if we could just have one central
account that we have two-factor
authentication set up in once and we
could use that security everywhere
this is the idea behind single sign-on
um and the idea behind single sign-on is
yeah is that you have the web apps that
we've been talking about previously now
um in this framework are known as
service providers they're the thing that
you they're the service that you want to
log into right
um that has control of your stuff
but you also now have an identity
provider and the job of this this entity
is simply to to be able to verify that
you are who you say you are and the
service provider can trust the
information of the identity provider and
so what sso is is essentially the
service providers delegate that
authentication responsibility to the
identity provider
and the way this works sort of
mechanistically is as follows
you've got oh well yeah the benefits of
this sorry uh the identity provider
you've got one centralized identity and
the benefits of this are that you can do
your two-fact authentication in one
place
you can also make updates to your
identity let's say somebody changes
their name people do this all the time
and you can change central identity
management centralized identity
management right you can see those
changes and that security reflected
against across all of the accounts that
delegate their responsibility of
authentication to that identity provider
how it works mechanistically is as
follows
you go to your service provider and you
say i'd like to log in
and your service provider redirects you
to the identity provider and at this
point you authenticate with whatever
method you have set up you could be
using all six different layers of
multi-factor authentication if you
really wanted to
and you are authenticated there the
identity provider knows who you are and
has done its job and then it sends you
back to the service provider with some
kind of token of proof that the service
provider can use to understand who you
are and trust that the identity provider
has center correct information so
this should all this entire process
should be cryptographically signed right
with the you know everybody being able
to trust that the entities they're
talking to has actually sent the
messages that they claim to have sent
um the service provider is able to
interpret that token somehow verify it
and let you log in and get out your
stuff
so
how do we actually do it
delegating our authentication to a third
party
there are a couple frameworks um
sorry
i'm racing ahead of myself i want to get
to my saml rant um right so benefits are
web services don't need to store user
credentials this is great it means that
if my pinterest is hacked if pinterest
gets its database leaked but i logged in
with google pinterest doesn't know
anything about me other than the fact
that google is responsible for telling
it who i am right and this means that
actually
although it seems like you're
concentrating all your security in one
place and putting all your eggs in one
basket it means that actually
smaller web apps can take advantage of
the security budget of bigger places
like big identity providers and they
don't actually need to worry quite so
much about their own security i mean
they still should but they don't need to
um and users don't need to remember a
lot of passwords they only need to
remember like one horrible long string
of digits cool
one downside is that if your identity
provider gets popped
so do all your other accounts i know
octa is sponsoring here so i will not
say too much about that but yes um
you are putting all your eggs on my
basket and you very much hope that
basket does not get dropped
how can we implement it yes here we go
we've got saml security assertion markup
language um which was where this this
was sort of the first go at this and it
it came to life mostly in corporate
environments
um and then we also have open id connect
and this is the one that has sort of
taken hold over the wider web
let's take a deep dive samuel
so it follows that same basic framework
you go to your saml service provider and
for the sake of this example let's say
that this is you you are an employee
acme corp and this is your hr system
right you go to your sample service
provider your hr system and it goes you
need to log in i'm going to send you via
a browser redirect to the identity
provider
and along with that browser redirect in
as
sort of in the query string of that of
that um http
is a saml authentication request and
this is a blob of xml data and it should
be cryptographically signed
um the sample identity provider
authenticates you and then sends you
back
with a saml authentication assertion
asserting who you are and that the
samuel provider service provider should
trust you
this should also be cryptographically
signed
and the samwell service provider is able
to parse that xml assertion and say yes
i know who you are you can get it your
hr system or whatever
um one cool thing about this is the
browser it all happens where your
browser redirects with xml in the query
string right and that actually means
that your service the identity provider
doesn't need to be in uh connected to
the wider web
uh it can actually be within like a an
air-gapped corporate network
but the service provider could be on the
web so i could be using my
very locked down like acme corp
credentials to log into things that are
on the public web that's pretty cool
it's mostly it's mostly kind of um
conceptually cool but it is cool
um however samuel has some problems
signing xml data which you have to do
because you should be cryptographically
assigning all of your communications
signing out my data is really really
really hard
and this is because cryptographic
signing works over byte strings and here
are two byte strings
they represent the same data right but
they're different they've got different
spaces and as far as xml is concerned
these two things are the same
as far as signing it with cryptographic
with the
public private key pair is concerned
these are not the same they will
generate two different signatures
um we need some way to understand that
these both mean oh the issuer is
whatever
and there is a way to do this you can
take both of these strings and convert
them into some kind of semantic
understanding right and this process is
called canonicalization
it's it's hard it's complicated there
are arguments about how to do it there
are three i think at least three
different canonicalization algorithms in
the saml specification
there is no consensus on the best way to
do this
and once you've canonicalized your data
you can reconstitute it into some
reliably it's always going to be the
same the same canonical form will always
translate into the same byte string and
then you can sign over that right
but here's the issue is that your
service provider and identity provider
you need to make sure that not only are
they using the same algorithm in the
same way preferably with the same
library which is going to be hard if one
is doing it in javascript and one is
doing it in your server language of
choice
you need to make sure they're doing that
the same you need to make sure they're
both getting it right
um this is really really hard it
presents a huge attack surface um there
have been saml breaches where somebody
with a well-placed comment you can just
sign in as an admin with absolutely no
like you know anybody can just sign in
as an admin to saml based authentication
systems um really cool really fun quite
scary and
new exploits aren't found that
frequently
but they are like they could still be
found the the the possibility for them
because of this complexity of
canonicalization and the flexibility of
xml means that insecurity is kind of
kind of baked in to samuel
um
so
it did work for a long time for a long
time that was how we did sso um but now
we have open id connect and this is now
the the this is the one that you will
have seen if you've ever seen a screen
like this
then you have used oidc oh uh you have
used oidc to log into somewhere
um
and the difference is between
we'll see how it works and we'll discuss
the differences between it and saml and
why this has taken over the internet and
samuel didn't but the process looks uh
oh yeah you go odc doesn't use xml it
doesn't have this canonicalization
problem it uses json web tokens these
are far more restricted in format and
they do have a single best practice for
canonicalization and cryptographic
signing which means that you don't have
the same kind of vulnerabilities
introduced by potential mismatches
between those two things
another difference is that tokens are
parsed by the service provider once that
token factor in this case a json web
token is returned to the service
provider it can read it it can
understand the data out of it but it
also has the option to send it back to
the identity provider for verification
and this provides an extra difficulty
against somebody if somebody sends a
malicious illegitimate token to a
service provider the service provider
doesn't just have to trust it it can
actually go back to the identity
provider that it knows and say hey i got
hold of this token um is it legit and
the identity provider can say yes or no
this also allows the identity provider
to revoke access at any time which is
pretty handy if you've got lots of
things that you sign into with google
and you want to stop doing that you can
just sign it to google and say hey
revoke access for this one service
so the way that it works is pretty
similar with some a few extra steps at
the end
in oidc world the identity provider is
called the authentication server this is
something it inherits from being built
on top of oauth
um and a lot of the structure of oidc is
sort of comes from having billboards on
top of this authorization uh system and
the difference between authentication
and authorization is a talk in its own
right i will not be going into that
you go to your service provider
pinterest
say i want to log in i want to log in
with google and pinterest says cool
great go to google authorize like go to
the authorized endpoint and identify
yourself you are authenticated there
using your fingerprint your 2fa whatever
you've got going on
and then the authentication server sends
you back to the service provider with an
authorization code
and this is oh this is one of the this
is one of the iodc files this is sort of
the the main golden path oidc flow
an authorization code and the service
provider now has this code you your role
as the user is now done you have
authenticated the service provider takes
that authorization code and it says hey
authentication server i've got this auth
code
mint me some tokens i want to know who i
want to know what this code means and it
hits a token endpoint
the authentication server says yep sure
i recognize that code i just issued it i
can tell you what it means and let me
issue you an id token and this is
something that the service provider can
can read it's a json web token and say
oh i know who this person is now right
um if it does want to do any extra
verification it can send that id token
back to an introspect endpoint and say
well i've got this id token who is this
person tell me more about them to give
me their email and stuff
um
and
the oodc authentication server will not
only
give information if the person if their
service provider has requested it but it
can also verify that that token is
legitimate so i as a sort of a malicious
attacker can't just send an id token to
the service provider and expect it to
trust it because it it can always go
back to the actual legitimate identity
server and and ask it if that's true
so and at this point the service
provider goes yeah okay that's been
verified have access to your stuff
and this is the one that's basically yes
taken over it's taken of the internet
and because of this you get all of the
benefits of sso
um yeah the centralized identity
identity management um only changing
things in one place being able to do a
2fa in one place
right
that concludes the tour of all of the
options of ways that the sort of typical
ways you have of authenticating your
users everybody drinks some water i know
i need to
right
we know what authentication is
and now we know how to do it
but what we're going to talk about in
the final section is what makes an
authentication system good
right you are building a web app and
you're choosing what how you're going to
make sure you know who your users are
what should you consider well obviously
security right if you've got an insecure
system you might as well not have it
um and to that end i want to go back to
the first example that we looked at
which is username and password
if done correctly this is secure
if your server only stores salted hashes
and your user remembers passwords that
look like this
and if your users don't reuse their
passwords which means that they have to
remember a lot of passwords that look
like this
um
if something is hard to use
securely it's insecure passwords your
password-based systems are hard to use
securely for your users it requires
difficult behaviors that are not
intuitive and not it's not usable right
um and this means that you'll end up
with users doing things like yeah
reusing passwords putting them on sticky
notes on their computers which is
actually not as bad as reusing them
honestly
and the thing is you might say well i
have really clever users right i have
sophisticated users maybe my users are
also developers they know all this stuff
smartest person i know put their master
password into slack
uh doesn't matter how clever your users
are
you need to build your system to account
for the fact that they will make
mistakes
so if something is hard to use securely
it's insecure so we have now security
and ease of use
and you might think that these two
things are kind of in tension
and to some extent that's true but there
are there's also um a consideration
where
like let's say that i want to use
one-time password-based system for my
for my web app and i don't want to use
text-based
one-time passwords because they're
insecure reddit had a leak because their
admin team was using text-based uh
one-time passwords and somebody managed
to break that
um but the thing is maybe my users don't
all have smartphones so i can't use an
authenticator app for that because they
don't all have devices with that
capability
because text-based messaging the text
message-based one-time passwords are
usable they're easy to use they're easy
to access for a lot of people um unless
you live in someone with no service you
have to run down the road to get code
it makes it it makes it more accessible
it's better than not having anything as
a second factor right
um so just because something is
not the most secure thing in the world
doesn't mean you shouldn't consider it
as an option better that's better than
nothing right
um so we've got security and ease of use
right
and again if done correctly
saml is secure if you make sure that
your sample libraries are up to date and
cover all their own vulnerabilities you
make sure that your service provider and
your identity provider are using the
same ones and they've both got it right
um
but here's the thing is that's a lot of
overhead for you you've got to stay on
top of like people who are trying to
crack these kind of systems and
like reporting their findings you have
got to do a lot of overhead when you're
actually setting up your system do a lot
of research into like why saml is
difficult to do correctly
um you know as far as a user is
concerned it's super easy to use it's
single sign-on
um
but sound-based systems although they
can be done securely very rarely are
if something is hard to implement
securely then it's going to be insecure
um so we come to the third pillar of the
things that i think you should care
about when you're doing an
authentication system is security ease
of use and ease of implementation
um you know usability doesn't just
matter for our users it matters for us
too uh we're people too we deserve to
not have to deal with things that are
going to be really hard to do
or needlessly hard to do i should say
so i think that these are the things
that you need to care about when you're
choosing your authentication system and
designing it you need to care about who
your users are and what kind of things
they have access to you need to care
about who your developers are what their
strengths are and what they're going to
have to maintain and above all you're
going to have to care about security
so
um
that about wraps it up we have talked
about what authentication is why you
care about it we've gone through all the
different options that you have for
authenticating well i mean not all of
them but a pretty comprehensive whistle
stop tool of all the options that you
have for authenticating users and some
of their pros and cons
and we have finally talked about what
makes an authentication system good
and the fact that usability really
matters not just for our users but for
us as well
thank you very much um i've been eli
holdeness and there is time for
questions or you're welcome to go and
get some lunch
[Applause]
any questions i won't be offended if
there aren't any